au dessus de la colonne de marbre
vestiges de la grande synagogue de
varsovie posé sur l'urne contenant des
cendres de victimes d'auschwitz
la flamme éternelle rappelle les
millions de morts en entretenant le
centre commémoratif de l'holocauste nous
rappelle aussi que montréal a été pour
les survivants la troisième destination
en importance après tel aviv et new york
renato 9 86 ans avait 10 ans quand la
guerre a commencé et la ques d'ottawa ce
matin j'ai eu de la chance d'être avec
ma mère sans cela je ne serais pas ici
nous dit elle dans un anglais mâtiné
d'accent polonais originaire de cracovie
elle a survécu avec sa mère et sa soeur
au ghetto rendu célèbre par la liste de
schindler au camp de concentration de
poids chauffe d'office et de bergen
belsen son père et le reste de la
famille n'ont pas eu la même chance
poite à pois souffle nous devions courir
tout autour du camp complètement nue se
rappelle-t-elle et ma mère m'a dit tu ne
regarde personne tu ne dis rien tu court
aussi vite que tu peux jusqu'à ce que tu
retournes à ta baraque rhénan a attendu
40 avant de pouvoir en parler
le temps de se refaire une vie d'élever
ses enfants ici à montréal puis paul
peny personne n'aurait voulu nous croire
et puis on a commencé à organiser des
marches commémoratives les marche des
vivants à auschwitz et dans d'autres
camps d'extermination myspace est têtue
audio titre ou encore au début je ne
voulais pas et puis mon mari m'a dit tu
dois y aller les jeunes générations
doivent savoir dit elle
elle a participé pour témoigner à 12
voyages et les minions aussi un rôle
important après le génocide dans le
grand hall de l'hôtel de ville de
montréal une exposition souligne le jour
du souvenir de l'holocauste
trois autres génocide du xxème siècle
l'arménie le cambodge le rwanda ils sont
commémorées les signes avant coureurs
ont presque toujours été les mêmes faire
une différence entre nous
les autres et l'autre ça va être
comparée à de la vermine à des rats on
va les mettre
on va les séparer depuis plusieurs
années le centre de commémoration de
l'holocauste fait un travail de mémoire
sur de nombreux génocide dont les
survivants se sont refait une vie ici à
montréal
il faut continuer en fait à apprendre
des génocides passés pour pouvoir
justement essayer de prévenir les
génocides futur savoir reconnaître les
signes avant-coureurs comprendre les
mécanismes tout ça compte bien sûr mais
il faut avant tout avoir la volonté le
courage politique pour les prévenir
alexandra schatz qu'à radio-canada
montréal